[Musique]
jour de gloire pour une famille
politique rebaptisé voici les
républicains pour leur premier congrès
c'était le 30 mai 2015
ce changement de nom n'est pas le
premier dans l'histoire de la droite
républicaine loin de là déjà en 1958
charles de gaulle change le nom de son
parti fini le rpf d'après guerre le
rassemblement du peuple français
créée en 1947 est en sommeil depuis 1955
place à l'umr l'union pour la nouvelle
république
ce matin annonce le retour du général en
politique
ils coïncident avec les 80 2% du oui au
référendum pour la mise en place de la
cinquième république
l'union pour la nouvelle république que
je représente ici à d'abord ce but
précis de faire en sorte que les
institutions nouvelles approuvé par la
majorité des français fonctionne
loyalement et efficacement et aussi
aider le général de gaulle à remettre la
france de l'umr de 20 en 1967 l'union
des démocrates pour la 5ème république
devenu après quelques mois eu des airs
union des démocrates pour la république
plus union pour la défense de la
république
à l'origine un nouveau long pour
rassembler les candidats gaullistes aux
législatives et des non inscrits alliés
au mouvement ici réunis
967 ressuscité grâce à charles de gaulle
et en poney il change encore de nom en
1976 lui dr devient le rpr rassemblement
pour la république créée par jacques
chirac
cette entité est une manière de remettre
le gaullisme sur le devant de la scène
en opposition au président valéry
giscard d'estaing le grand rassemblement
auquel je vous convie devra allier la
défense des valeurs essentielles du
gaullisme
en 2002 jacques chirac rebaptise le rpr
en ump à l'origine trois lettres
signifiant union pour la majorité
présidentielle
il s'agit de rassembler les candidats
rpr et udf pour les législatives
elles sont ensuite devenus l'acronyme d'
union pour un mouvement populaire
le nom des droites saluée par certains
militants c'est la marche vers les
partis uniques
l'ump reste sur toi social nicolas
sarkozy mais surtout aux scandales à
répétition pour relancer le parti
nouveau changement de nom en 2015 les
républicains aient l'air approuvé par
les ténors du parti l'ump pour moi était
une image qui traînait derrière elle un
certain nombre l'histoire du passé des
conflits entre copé et fillon les
affaires bygmalion et cetera et cetera
depuis les républicains se sont
illustrés la présidentielle de 2017 par
une guerre intestine dès l'investiture
et un score de 15,6 pour cent
c'est la première fois que la droite ne
passe pas au second tour
[Musique]